hey Debbie happy birthday Peter 20 years
of friendship can you believe it how do
you still speak to me do you remember
the first night we met
stops being weird it's so weird
Debbie you need to take a break I just
need to be practical which is what you
have to be when you're a single mom
right
I got an idea I'm coming to La for a
week I'm gonna look after Jack and you
can stay here I don't know you need help
let me help taking care of Jack is a lot
of work I think I got this I hope that
you get what you want out of this trip
find yourself a hottie maybe get waxed
waxed oh waxed waxed oh well that's just
not gonna happen
this place is amazing hi I'm Debbie the
Debbie theater talks about you all the
time I am a coach embarrassed I'm not
wearing anything under this oh don't
worry about it we've all done the thing
where we knock on the door half naked
for some
[Music]
who says you're terrible with women yeah
she does huh so what happens next can we
stay on message you always answer a
question with a question do you always
answer a question to a question about
the question okay
okay so how's your love life now sort of
like an old ghost town he's yummy wait
where are you going I have no idea what
to say to this guy can I get your number
oh my God
here
you and I tell each other everything
right always I think I may have met
someone
can I tell you something immediately the
night that Debbie and Ike spent together
after I found myself thinking about her
you have to tell her it's too late
[Music]
seriously these are words
what is all this Peter's not interested
in me like that is he
I feel like we should see what you and I
could be
this is a minor setback right
that's it
so what are you gonna do
[Music]
[Music]